لقد قلت بنفسك أنك
فقدت أفرادًا مهمين من عائلتك، أعني أنني
أعتقد أنه شيء مثل 44
فردًا من عائلتك، لقد قلت أه أعني
أبناء العمومة والأقارب البعيدين من
هم
نعم، هؤلاء أقارب لي أه
الـ 44 فردًا من  تضم العائلة واحدًا حصل على
أعلى الدرجات في المدرسة الثانوية الوطنية،
والثاني طبيب جيد جدًا
كان يعمل في مستشفى الشفاء، وكلاهما
أفراد مؤهلون تأهيلاً عاليًا
ويستحقون العيش ويستحقون بناء
دولة ستنشأ بدلاً من ذلك، كما
تعلمون  تم استهدافنا وكان هناك
العشرات والعشرات من الفلسطينيين، لذلك
أشعر ليس فقط بعائلتي المباشرة، بل أيضًا
بعائلة فلسطين الممتدة التي
يتم استهدافها، وإذا كان هناك أي شيء
يشعر كل فلسطيني أن هذا ليس
سوى تطهير عرقي سيؤدي
إلى واقع مختلف على الأرض
الأرض بدلاً من حل الصراع،
فهي مجرد ترسيخ المزيد والمزيد من
الكراهية، وهذا شيء
لا ينبغي للإنسانية أن تستقبله أبداً، وما
يجب أن يستمتع به هو
مستقبل مختلف لجميع الفلسطينيين ووقف
الجنون الذي تعلم به أن المنازل
تُقصف على الرؤوس.  أه وأطراف
أه أطفال ونساء وشيوخ، من
الواضح أن هذه الحكومة الحالية
لم تكن تريد أن تعرف
حل الدولتين، نحن نعرف ذلك ولكن
رئيسكم السابق ياسا عرفات
رفض أيضًا أفضل عملية سلام
واتفاقات سلام تم طرحها على الإطلاق
الطاولة ولسوء الحظ، أنت تعلم أن هذه
حقيقة وأتساءل عما إذا كان من الممكن أن
يصل هذا الأمر الآن دون
إعادة النظر في التاريخ الذي سمعته للتو من
ضيفنا السابق أنه يجب أن يكون هناك
كيان ما يمثل
كيانًا فلسطينيًا شرعيًا يمكنه التدخل في
الثغرة عندما تندلع هذه الحرب  لقد انتهى الأمر إذا كنت
لا تزال تؤمن بإمكانية
السلام في حل الدولتين
كما تعلم ردًا على
سؤالك، فالأمور معقدة للغاية الآن،
ويضغط المجتمع الدولي الآن من أجل
واقع مختلف، وآمل بالتأكيد
أن تكون هذه المرة جيدة.  المجتمع
جاد في أه إقامة
علاقة جديدة وفتح آفاق جديدة
مع
جهود سلام دائم وموثوق ومستدام تؤدي
إلى إنشاء
دولة فلسطينية فقط لتوضيح
شيء واحد نعم كان هناك بعض أه سلام
أه خطوات يجب أن أقول  تجاهك تعرف
خلق واقع مختلف ولكن إسرائيل
لم تكن جادة أبدًا أي خريطة تم
تقديمها للرئيس عرفات أو لاحقًا للرئيس عرفات أو لاحقًا
لأه الرئيس أبوين حيث القطع التي
لا بأس بها، كما تعلم ليست ذات مصداقية على الإطلاق لقد
رأيناك تعرف أن الأراضي الفلسطينية
يتم جرفها مما يخلق حقًا
الزخم الصعب بالنسبة للفلسطينيين،
وكذلك الافتقار إلى المصداقية من جانب
العالم، حيث أنه كان هناك
1000 قرار من قرارات الأمم المتحدة
لم تنفذها إسرائيل،
الأمر الذي يلقي في الواقع الكثير من الشك
حول خيارات العالم الذي
يريد الآن  كن جادًا في
عملية السلام إذا كنت جادًا افعل ذلك أه
نار البحار مهمة أولويتها الأولى
أه المساعدات الإنسانية
إعمار غزة وقف
تهجير الفلسطينيين لخلق
واقع مختلف على الأرض
والانخراط في عملية سلام جادة للغاية
هذا  الوقت مصمم على عدم رؤية حرب أخرى
ومزيد من القتل وسفك الدماء